suzanne et roland de résidents du québec
ont fait 45 minutes de route pour venir
en ontario pour vendre les bouteilles
vides qu'ils ont ramassé au québec
le coffre de leur vie usd board si à
notre trajet vaut les plus paient ce
qu'est ccsa et plus
certes pas d'avocat bio chaque semaine
ils viennent ici rapporté des bouteilles
qui ne sont pas consigné au québec
ici on leur donne vingt cinq par
bouteille d'alcool aujourd'hui cela fait
60 dollars d'un stationnement que des
voitures immatriculées au québec et
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous et raquel
d'habitude d'être erreur puis d'être élu
anna lietti des fermes et le peuple est
debout take et bien qu'on pourra faire
et ce sera très bien raymond et sylviane
eux aussi sont venus en profiter les
croyants du ks 521 y pense pour
l'environnement en ontario la consigne
sur les bouteilles de vins et spiritueux
existe depuis 13 ans chaque année 233
millions de bouteilles sont récupérées
dans les biefs store et toutes les
brûler verte ensemble et blanches
ensemble depuis que la consigne a été
implanté en ontario le verre récupéré
mieux trier de meilleure qualité parce
qu'il n'est pas contaminé par d'autres
matières recyclables qu'avec les yeux
pour ça mon erreur
on manque de ça au québec c'est ce côté
l'or qui nous permettraient de justement
retourné nos bouteilles au québec et non
pas des temps fouilles dans des sites
d'enfouissement en ontario 87% des
bouteilles récupérées sont recyclés
tandis qu'au québec la très grande
majorité des bouteilles de verre
récupéré sont envoyés dans les sites
d'enfouissement
faute de qualité o'neill contre le
gaspillage s'empêcherait le monde de
gaspiller ont fait du corps passe en
fait j'ai de ce clash cofpa de la
consigne c'est la même chose
la plupart des québécois qui viennent
ici en ontario attendent avec impatience
le jour ils pourront retourner leurs
bouteilles chez eux au québec et si
jean-philippe robien radio canada
hawkesbury